let's talk about Donald Trump's rigged
election claims he's been claiming for a
while now that the election is rigged
that if indeed Hillary Clinton defeats
him on November 8th next Tuesday it will
be only because the election was rigged
now unfortunately for Trump the ways in
which the election is sort of rigged are
not ways that are favorable to Hillary
Clinton this includes Republican
gerrymandering of congressional
districts after the 2010 census this
includes the Republican effort to reduce
early voting hours and make it more
difficult to get the required ids to
vote in historically lower-income and or
non-white and/or Democratic areas
in-person voter fraud that the the kind
Trump is talking about millions of dead
people voting voting twice etc it's
really really rare however we now know
of at least one instance of this elusive
in-person voter fraud and it happens to
have been perpetrated by a Donald Trump
supporter voting twice because as she
put it the election is rigged against
Trump so she wanted to vote twice for
Trump I'm talking about 55 year-old
Terry wrote who was arrested on first
degree election misconduct charges after
trying to vote for Trump at two separate
polling stations in Des Moines Iowa late
last week she's a registered Republican
she went up to the Polk County Election
office to submit an early ballot and
shortly thereafter she went to a County
satellite voting location with a second
ballot and that's illegal that is called
voter fraud she was booked on a class D
felony it could land her in jail for up
to five years if convicted I would be
shocked if that actually happens now not
only is this rare as we know Terry wrote
story tells us that it is taken
seriously the Republicans and the right
and wrote Donald Trump and everybody
trying to pass these oppressive voter
suppression laws would have you believe
Pat that it's super easy to get away
with this
well Terry wrote faces five years in
prison now for it yeah the exchange is
five years in prison for one seemingly
inconsequential vote yeah you know when
Trump talks about voter fraud it seems
like he's hinting that it's being
conducted by racial minorities I talked
about Chicago even though he has no
chance of winning Illinois I mean this
could happen by anyone and in this case
it is a trump supporter and there's some
additional irony in addition to this
just being a Trump supporter because a
felony record in Iowa takes away your
right to vote altogether
Iowa not every state has that law Iowa
is known for being notoriously a you
know hard hard on felons with regard to
voting law these people do need to be
thrown in jail I mean it's funny and all
but you have to throw the book at people
who do this it's really really rare but
when it happens we have a system we have
a legal system in place and I want to
add to this that Trump has been talking
about in addition to talking about a
rigged election Trump has been talking
about how he is going he wants people to
sign up to be sort of election monitors
and next probably tomorrow tomorrow or
the next day we're going to talk about
how to be prepared for a potential voter
intimidation because Trump is lining up
this really harebrained and just
magnificently dreadful crew of people
deplorable in many cases that are going
to be at polling places aggressively
intimidating would-be voters we're going
to tell you what your rights are we're
going to tell you what these monitors
are allowed to do and not allowed to do
but very importantly we're going to tell
you number one how to identify whether
this is an actual official election
monitor and number two and this is maybe
the most important thing what to do if
you show up and there is someone
intimidating voters outside or hopefully
not but even inside a polling place I'm
done with this I voted on Friday I had
about a 30 30 minutes total it took to
vote at Boston City Hall and I've been
told that the lines on November 8th will
be much much worse
so hopefully I've saved myself some time
for people who haven't voted and
particularly if you'll be voting on
November 8th tomorrow or the next day we
will talk to you all about protecting
yourself from voter intimidation I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman of course we are on
Reddit at david pakman.com slash read at
re d di t
discuss any of these stories or others
that are important to you there I think
it is really great that we have movement
watches as a sponsor on the show I've
been thinking of getting a movement
watch for a while because I think that
they are really really cool and when
they came to us and said hey we would
like to sponsor some episodes of the
David Pakman show and we would like to
send you a free watch as you can imagine
I was thrilled and the entire story of
movement watches MVM t for short is not
that different from the David Pakman
show
in the sense that it started in college
it was built partially on crowdfunding
an IndieGoGo campaign much like what
we've done and the whole idea is that
these are the types of watches you would
go to a department store and probably be
stunned that you would have to pay 400
to 500 dollars for and instead movement
watches start at just 95 bucks if you're
watching with me you can see I have the
sort of white face a chronograph watch
and we have the picture here of the
darker face chronograph watch but
there's a whole bunch of different
options and my viewers and listeners can
actually get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to mV
MT watches dot-com / Pakman the watch I
picked has a super clean design
minimalist everywhere I go and people
see it they say what is that watch
that's really cool and the great thing
about it is it also tells time which now
increasingly I have no clue what time it
is with the election coming up and how
busy with we've been hours go by and I
don't even know what's going on and it
also does a good job of telling time
which is something a watch should do so
again MVM t-- watches dot-com / Pakman
PA KMA n 15% off free shipping free
returns I love my watch